also i just because of because of your
work i came across an exchange a few
emails with patrick mcgovern
who's basically what would you call him
so he has a center i guess that's
does biomolecular archaeology at upenn
and um he's the author of a bunch of
books one of which is ancient bruise
so he's a scholar of beer and wine
and and like ancient alcohol which is
fascinating they influenced even just
alcohol but he has like uh alcohol with
um
hallucinogenic properties as well but
it's fascinating as a russian it's
fascinating to uh
to think about the influence of alcohol
on the development
of human civilization throughout its
history is this is there something you
can comment on
alcohol or in general
patrick's work that was informative to
you inspiring or kind of
added to your conception of of human
history his work was some of the first
hard scientific data that i saw for the
ritual consumption of these intoxicants
um i don't think he's ever found the
hard and fast data for for psychedelics
but what he turned me on to was this
idea
that alcohol or beer and wine
specifically
could have been used as vehicles for the
administration of psychedelics that's
where it all started for me
just just the notion that ancient beer
and ancient wine is very very different
from what we drink today that typically
they were cocktails they were often
fortified and mixed with different
fruits berries herbs plants maybe even
fungi over time because this was all in
the absence of distilled liquor right
there is no hard alcohol even in russia
before
maybe the 12th century it was in europe
maybe a bit earlier um but the the
concept of distillation just didn't
exist and so
you know to pack a punch um
you know rather than just drink a kind
of watered-down budweiser these people
were interested in fortifying these
beverages with whatever they could find
in nature and and pat to his credit
found some of the initial data for these
um you could say spiked wines and spiked
beers not with anything overtly
psychedelic but just the fact that in
the 16th century bc
at grave circle a in my senai there's
this minoan ritual cocktail of beer
mixed with wine mixed with mead is very
interesting it's even more interesting
that you find that across the aegean
in gordium at king midas tomb right the
same kind of ritual cocktail which pat
and sam at the dogfish head brewery
resurrected as the midas touch so i mean
the notion that we can go back
find this data resurrect it in some
cases 2 800 years later i found pretty
exciting 10 years ago
yeah bring him back for research
but that's that's fascinating that
people were playing these ideas
you